hello everyone and welcome back to the
TCC Superfinal the the super final
already ended we are going to cover some
of the games since we were too busy
covering the online super tournaments
that were happening at the time this is
game 65 from the TCC season 18 the top
chess engines competition
Leela chess 0 wood white against stock
fish and it's quite the game we haven't
had a game like this in quite a while
but before we check out the game I would
just like to invite you to check out a
song about Paul Morphy it's the first
thing you see in the description below
do check it out
III enjoyed it myself thought you guys
might enjoy it so getting back to the
game Leela with the white pieces opens
with the d4 but the openings are
pre-arranged like for all of the 100
games it's all book moves up until a
certain point but we will mention that
tonight if 6 by stockfish we have c4 e6
and Knight f3 and Bishop to b4 now going
for the BOGO Indian defense Knight bTW
two blocking and now our stockfish
castles with a3 challenging the bishop
and best back to e7 we have E for
grabbing the center and d5 starfish
strikes in the center ePHI pushing the
knight back Knight ft7 and now Bishop to
b3 and here at c5 here Lila goes for h4
and this is the last book more so as of
mu9 stockfish is on his own so he goes
for g6 and now a popular move amongst
human grandmasters is h5 but here Oliva
decides to go for castles instead we
have Knight to c6 and now Knight to b3
opening up the dark square Bishop
diagonal the knight also helps out with
the defense of the d4 square and and so
on and here there are a few games that
reach this position for example C
capture Sun d4 is a known move D
captures on c4 was played in the 2018
but to me chess olympiad between Dingley
owned and even shot H were our strategy
captured on c4 Dean liván was able to
win that game but here stockfish goes
for just a plain old pawn grab with
Bishop characters on h4 as we all know
stockfish is a pawn grabber and now this
is a new move so already as a move 11 a
completely new game so Leela continues
with Bishop to h6 puts pressure on the
rook here look back to I ate and now
rook to e1 we have some trades in the
center seek actress on d4 but first
Queen to c2 there's always time to
recapture here as the pawn is attacked
twice so there is no rush
so the capture is on c4 stuffy grabs yet
another pawn and the bishop characters
on c4 now we have Knights to be six
attacking the bishop and now it seems
like a pretty normal move to just bring
the bishop back however lil I decided
that there's no need to bring the bishop
back just rotated e1 complete complete
and full development we have Bishop to
d7 by stockfish and now comes a knight
the c5 putting pressure on the b7 pawn
but stockfish is you know no beginner at
calculating line so he just goes rook to
c8 he says I have at it
grab that b7 pawn but it's not doing
anything for y for example if knife
captures Queen c7 you have to go back
with the night and now Knights the a5 a
double attack on the bishop by both
Knights a double attack on the night
here and it's well I things have gone
wrong for white so instead allelic Jones
goes b4 and here we have Knight captures
on c4 we have Queen captures on c4 and
now yes so you constantly don't have to
worry about this Bishop on h4 go should
be back to east 7 attacking the knight
and c5 and Knight to e4 which makes
sense this point covers both of these
squares so you can go Knight d6 you can
go Knight to f6 and so on however there
is the problem of this nasty discovery
so if the knight moves there's a nasty
discovery on the Queen and that's
exactly what stops issues the C goes
from Knight character son before now
opens the discovery the knight is nicely
defended so it's not a problem here or
is it because here we've reached the
position from the thumbnail and here at
Lille I just captured the night Lilla
played Queen captures on b4 and our are
the Queen's really that overrated so
what's happening here well obviously you
have to capture the Queen so Bishop
captures and now you have to be very
careful for example if you try Knight f6
check to throw in a nice move before
recapturing the bishop black will just
pick up the night and now after
characters you will also lose the rook
and after all is said and done you
we'll have this position where black is
up to pawns make yeah make the three
points three points and also is of the
exchange so black would be completely
winning here
so after this Queen sacrifice Lila just
recaptures on before and says what are
you going to play now night if six is
coming then Knight g5 is coming I might
be able to capture here I might be able
to capture there how a stock fish
countering this so first stock which
starts with f5 at least he frees up the
DF 7 square for the king and okay Knight
f6 check we have King to h8 and now not
grabbing material but rather rook
captures on d4 there's now a double
attack on the bishop here and if you
were able to capture that maybe the
Queen moves and then row captures and h7
will just be checkmate so rook c7
stockfish adds another defender and rook
eat a d1 Leela adds another attacker to
the bishop we have looked the east 7
adding another defender and now there's
no way to add yet another attacker to
the d7 Bishop so you just start
improving the position would be 5 stock
which goes for b6 and we have King 2 h2
now Lila wants to bring the King all the
way to g5 we've cooked the b7 stockfish
has no good moves you can't really do
anything with with the rooks you can't
move the bishop and there's not nothing
else so stop which just has to wait here
Knight g5 by Leela and now Queen to see
it unpinning but it's not all that much
Oro quantity to alia just grabs more
space with the rooks and you can't move
the Queen
I mean God and the bishop falls if you
move the bishop then let's say you
capture this then just rock the 8 check
and it's a game over you lose the Queen
and very soon the game so after Luke 1
d2 we have worked the c7 stockfish the
the sad stockfish has to repeat moves
here and now
rook the d6 grabbing even more space we
have looked back the b7 and now rook 2
to D for grabbing even more space we
have looked the c7 and now rook back to
d1 something I often called the dance of
the engines because even though these
moves do make sense in some you know a
long long variation to us humans they
really don't so I just call it the dance
of the engines
ruk the b7 and now rook 6a back to d4 we
have looked the c7 and now finally as
allele a depleted all the other options
it continues with f4 finally a pawn move
rook back to b7 and now there there are
a good ways to continue this but Lila
just goes for the more straightforward
one
but even feel free to pause the video
here and try to figure out what Lilla
played how do you improve here well I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations
unsporting that the e6 pawn well is free
for grabs and for those who just won't
enjoy the show it's Knight captures an
e6 and now of course you still can't
capture with the bishop because of rugby
8 so rook captures an e6 but now Knight
captures on d7 if you're thinking about
rook captures with the idea of rook may
adjust delivery mate after a trade
happens here it doesn't really work
because after captures and captures yes
you are threatening mate but there's
also rook f6 and after characters just
captures and you are completely lost so
you are doing well don't mess it up so
after rook captures any 6 we have Knight
captures by Lila now again with the
threat of just moving the night anywhere
and delivering rogue d8 check which will
end the game so King to g8 stop which
has to bring the King away from the
corner with Knight f6 check King f7 and
now rook the d8 finally going after the
Queen Queen to c5 and now Knight
captures on h7 now the knight can come
to g5 and it will not be pleasant for
the black King and also there's the
threat of the immediate checkmate for
example if you play a silly move like a
5 then just Knight g5 check King g7 and
Bishop f8 is checkmate
this is covered this is covered covered
covered covered and there is nothing to
be done here for the black King
so rook to e8 at least now you cover the
f8 square so white does not have Knight
g5 followed by Bishop - FA - checkmate
however there is another move here now
II 6 with check and this is super
problematic because if you capture with
the King rook e1 check just leads the
mate after king f7 now you do have 95
check King of 6 and just row characters
here with checkmates the fall
very quickly so after this ecigs check
mo chakra decides okay it's time to
capture with the rook but now the rook
is no longer covering the back rank and
now Knight to g5 with check also with a
nice fork here King f6 and now rook the
f8 with check and now you have to give
up the Queen if you go for rook f7 then
Rho captures and f7 is checkmate so you
have to go for Queen captures and f8 but
now just the Bishop captures and now
okay it's only a bishop and the night
against the rook however black is
completely lost here black can never
move the rook from from the 6th rank so
rook to c7 stockfish the sad stuff which
in this game forced the repeat moves
with this rook now rugby 4 and again the
problem is you can never move this rook
away white can capture it it will if you
move it anywhere just rook checks ro
cast the block and this again will be
checkmate
so after look before we have looked to
b7 again I mean imagine if you if you
were playing stockfish like you know
from a human standpoint and you force
him to repeat moves like that I mean how
how good would that feel but yeah I
guess we will never find out hello King
g3 Leelanau wants the plan King to H or
captured the rook and then bring the
King over to g5 to enter a completely
winning endgame so look back to c7 and
now rook the d3 not allowing this check
but now look back the b7 stockfish is
without a move King to h4 by Leela we
have looked back to c7 and now not going
for the capture right away but back King
back to g3 again they go into their
dance of the engines which you know will
just never understand
rook the c4 and now that the rook
finally moved from the seventh rank
finally worked a d7 but everything else
is completely losing too so it doesn't
really matter
look the e3 check by stalkerish King f2
and now there is nothing more to be done
this will be checkmate so stockfish
tried a few more checks check characters
Andrew K 4 but now it's just Bishop to
e7 with check preserving the knight King
to e5 now ok you can move to e5 finally
but now king of three and it was in this
position on mu 53 that stockfish
resigned the game
the material advantages just too big and
of course they both agreed that the
advantage is is much too large to
continue this game for black so really
really an impressive game III don't
remember when was the last time we had
we had one this good that Queen captures
on b4 move was was you know nothing
short of spectacular and and it's not
just Queen captures its Queen captures
the bishop captures so the Queen has
been sacrificed and I will just
recapture and you give black the move
saying I am completely winning here so
really amazing game and I do hope you
guys enjoyed it like I said do check out
the song about Paul Morphy first thing
in this first thing in the description
below
you guys might enjoy it I would like to
thank Matt Howells a similar core Anita
Shai gross amariah good and Mathew grow
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Paul Morphy saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day